did John's connection with a plane is
higher like Nick zero yeah zero zero
suggests going to Hollywood I know
thanks now when he's bullcrapping us or
bluffing I know there it is Nick Queens
Nick Queens like I really envisioned him
he just they just got out of a meeting
talking about Nick falls and he went in
there and like how to try to act like he
had no clue what the reporters were
asking about their what a crazy question
the news last week was that the Eagles
would not be applying to franchise tag
to quarterback Nick falls the deadline
by the way Tuesday at 4 p.m. Eastern for
all teams to apply the tag if they're
going to and that was an indication that
the Eagles have not been able to find a
trade partner because they would have
done the tag and trade if they could
have gotten some value for Nick fall so
he becomes a free agent less bone in
Philly calm says that outside of
Jacksonville the market has not
developed for Nick Foles and the Jaguars
absolutely expect to sign Superbowl 50
to MVP Nick Foles win free agency opens
here's the thing though Chris yeah if
the Jaguars are the only team that wants
the guy how much money is he gonna get I
got the over-under at 25 million a year
and I'm starting to think it might be
under yeah I think so too
I mean I still think the teams even
though hey Nick Foles won a Super Bowl
and had a nice run again this past
season I still don't think teams are
gonna buy into go Oh Nick Foles is this
bonafide franchise face of the franchise
starting quarterback they're also gonna
look at the fill why not tell me why not
because they're gonna look at this
they're gonna look at the film from the
start of the last season when the team
wasn't playing well and they're gonna go
out Nick Foles couldn't get them over
the hump in some of those games and make
the proper place that's what that's why
and then they're gonna go into his
history yeah we could talk about the
Rams and how that was bad and their team
was bad around him and all that but he
got another chance with the Kansas City
Chiefs too when Alex Smith got a
concussion and the team basically
just set out we're gonna play Nick Foles
this week even though Alex Smith was
ready and back and ready to play so that
didn't impress people so those little
things I think are going to detract from
his value altogether but either way I
like this signing for the Jacksonville
Jaguars Mike all the way Jacksonville is
in win mode right now their team is in
the window they are a you know what I
think their defense is a Superbowl
defense their offensive line when
healthy is one of the best in football
for net is still a really good running
back and I think they're looking at it
going do we really want to take the
chance of getting a rookie quarterback
in number seven or having to trade up to
get a quarterback with this team we have
right now that we think can be legit in
the AFC and maybe get back to an AFC
championship like we saw in 2017 and I'm
gonna push back on you a little bit of
relates to 2016 I'll agree with you the
2015 was a disaster for Nick Falls but
what Rams quarterback when Jeff Fisher
was coach didn't have a disastrous time
with the Rams the chances he had in
Kansas City I'm looking at the 2016
stats against Indianapolis he came in
for Alex Smith in that game he completed
16 of 22 passes for 223 yards that's
10.1 average per attempt passer rating
that day of 135 two touchdowns no picks
the next week he beat the Jaguars in a
start he was 20 of 33 with one touchdown
no picks his passer rating was only 86
point three that day how many yards he
not have he had 187 yards at 5.7 so not
nearly as good as the last but those are
the two games he played and that's the
one start you're referring to right when
maybe they could have put Alex Smith
back on the field right but that's a far
cry from 2015 I look at it this way yeah
consider the guys making 25 million more
in that range of 25 to 30 Derek Carr
what's he ever done when it counts I
hear you even Garoppolo what's he done
when it counts Matthew Stafford what's
he done when it counts Kirk Cousins for
crying out loud you know I feel about
that you got a guy who's taking the
Eagles to the top of the mountain how
does he not get 25 million a year yeah I
understand it be close to whether he
gets that but I would argue no Matthew
Stafford had years of carrying his team
too through the season and carrying his
team to the playoffs three times you
know Nick Foles though too
hey listen he is really good we know
that I I'm just not saying he's a
bonafide face of the franchise quite guy
he hasn't proved that that Eagles team
around him was very good we know that as
well and he can be in a similar
situation in Jacksonville with the
offense that he's familiar with and you
could say watch out for the Jaguars if
it all works out maybe the Jaguars would
like to trade for Kirk Cousins the
Vikings could sign dick Falls that's an
eye
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports